[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk necromancer
i said
five
now you know
since i'm doing this i get a little
leeway i feel like that's
[Music]
take time
[Music]
[Music]
one second
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right i'm back i'm back
you guys
are doing the [ __ ] talking so i'm here
to accommodate the [ __ ]
i'm here i'm here
i'm here
so
let
let's get a little bit into this guys
man i'm waiting for the rest to get here
cognito's still at work doing something
we got king david i probably should send
them the the link to the zoom call i'll
be real with you that's probably my
fault i'm about to send that but what i
want to hear is i want to hear what are
your guys's impression that's going to
happen at this show
put it in put it in the chat man tell me
what you guys think is going to happen
[Music]
so
question just to clarify are you guys
having any issues
with the the stream whatsoever is it
buffering am i in
it says there's something wrong but i
don't see any issues on the stream
itself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
so what's going on you guys okay look i
sent out the stuff i was supposed to
send i'm waiting for them to come back
uh you will not i have i'm not gonna be
putting up my thing yet
what i need is a new bed frame that's
what i need
all right so let me go ahead and
start doing some stuff for you guys
i'm gonna do a screen cap
all right
[Music]
you guys should see
and hear me bye
what's up what's going on guys salva's
busy also right at it i saw has like 50
50 jaws man soft has like 50 jobs
he works hard man he works hard
all right just keep me
keep me updated
on the stream now i do know when stuff
like this happens there's a lot of
people streaming
so there's like a lot of issues with
youtube in general
there's the man of the hour
guys like my demon slayer shirt
like you guys know i'm a huge anime fan
man
you know i know who these people are but
you guys know how it is i can't
pronounce any of their names any of
their names but i know who they are
toshiro
you know i can pronounce duck deku
from my hero
i can definitely pronounce that
all right so let me go ahead and
pull up where we're watching this from
where you got okay
let me put in the chat
hold up
we giving you guys the opportunity
the opportunity
the manga for that series though good
man it's good
i i've i've really enjoyed um
i enjoyed demon slayer like
a lot i enjoy demon slayer a lot so we
got we got the poll down there for you
guys uh pretty much the poll is just
saying uh where you guys will want us to
stream it from uh you know it's entirely
up to you
i'm not gonna really try to
pull that too much
notice that we have a lot of people that
don't really
like
twitch
in in our community
and now my headset died
oh
oh my god
demon slayer was good it was good man it
was good
i'm really worried about that current
resolution thing i don't know if i could
change it
they usually close all of that
yeah there's not a lot i could do about
that
i'm ready for the blood-borne pc i will
say one thing
i will say one thing it definitely looks
like there's gonna be some stuff going
on there man
yeah you know i could run this show solo
i could do that if i had to i don't want
to but i could do that if i had to i
sent out the leaks
the lords will be here soon
hopefully
let me double check man
let me go to the facebook we got a
facebook group the iop facebook group
let me make sure that they coming
i know they're coming but let me tell
them
the link
is
has been
sent out
all right so this is what we're going to
do
all right let's make this fun this is
the pre-show with addicts the pre-show
without it
put a one in the chat
if you like
demon slayer a two in the chat if you
like attack on titan or three in the
chat if you like all uh if you like both
of them that's what one in the chat for
demon slayer two in the chat for attack
on titan three in the chat for both
can i get rid of this clothespool yeah
is that a iop facebook group um
i think the facebook group is
i think that is
for
i don't know
i'll have to look i think it's lords of
gaming.net i don't know
king is coming
look look flame4 is not an option all
right i didn't give you four as an
option
stop taking advantage of the system
that though
right there little anonymous right there
death note
i like you man i like you
death thought's a good show
ghost in the shell i don't know about
that man okay look okay anime
how many of you seen the stranger things
man no no spoiling in the chat none of
that no spoiling but how who's watched
the uh the new season of stranger things
and put like a one out of ten if you
guys liked it one for dog
10 for amazing dog [ __ ] 10 for amazing
you guys know how it is uh
or one for bad i know i shouldn't cuss i
i'm gonna calm that down so one for bad
ten for amazing
um
oh someone said 9.5
all right playstation has their own
state of play
so make sure it's coming through the
right setting
there we go
all right so
all right so let me go ahead
start getting everything the way it
should be you guys know how it is
got to make got to make me smaller you
know got to make me smaller
you know what i'll take out the
transition thing you could see how attic
does this all right so first first off
you got to have my my pearly face man
you know i got to be on the stream it's
a reaction if we ain't in the stream
what's the point
so the then what we do is we we take
this big black part right here and we
click that we say yo i want you
to grab
the state of play stream
and
why didn't that work
we go the state of play stream so now we
got the state of play stream going on
it's in the background while we in the
front now obviously when people show up
it's gonna change on there'll be more
boxes here clearly uh for right now the
only people i know that's going to be
here is me king and cog
that's all i know right now uh now i do
know that there's people in the chat
that we mess if you've been on the show
man we might get one of you man uh you
know
put in the chat if you want to to pop in
we can get one of you one of you if
you've been on a show before i don't
know if we have any content creators in
in the description
uh in the comment section but we we
might be able to snatch one here man we
might be able to snatch one
attic producer 101 that's
i'm giving you guys
free
stuff man free stuff
the show should have full screen i'm
gonna be honest
so you know we got this
we got me
advi advise it would be better without
you talking man you guys are rude
you guys are rude
but i love it man i love it
i don't
care
i don't care be rude
all right so what is going on
with zoom
all right so no one
all right so we're fine on that
all right so we're fine with that for
right now
we're just waiting for
show this
is it not full screen it's full screen
i mean just out of curiosity would you
guys want me to like
put it up a little bit and put it below
this kind of like this
do you guys really care if you don't see
like
five like an inch of the screen you know
get give me some feedback man some
feedback
what you guys think's the better man cog
is coming so is king
so how how do you guys how would you
prefer to watch it
uh hustle is doing something else
better
what's that cartman from south park
better
all right so
put a one in the chat for the way i did
it which was this way
or put a two in the chat if you want me
to put the screen above
the the thing itself
one in the chat for it being behind uh
for the whole thing being behind us or
two in the chat if you want it just
moved a little bit so you could see the
full screen
i'm going to get like see the the senses
of what the majority want
there's a lot there's some twos man
looks like some twos
some
ones one two two
one
two
two
one
one one
man it's real close man it's real close
i don't know i think
but
i understand where you're coming from
stone but there's a lot like in the
reaction community people want to see
your face that's just how it is
people want to see your face
oh my god
you guys are ridiculous
like on boom's podcast
put on the side
uh so you want to like i don't know how
boom does his
you want it like this
is is this what i'm getting
right um
so so we'll make that three put a three
if you like that a one if you like the
original one where it's just full screen
or two if you want it on the bottom
um
so you it would you guys want it like
this
three three three yeah that's cool three
three
three three jeez every two
three three looks like everybody likes
three all right so what we'll do is this
is going to look real
real funky
uh it does look like the majority of
them like three so uh we're going to
keep it like this it might have some
black background stuff going on
but i will have a template made
for this stuff to make it look nice the
next time we do one
i got you guys man i got you guys
all right all right so this is what
we're gonna do
the the the attic show pre-show is over
all right for i'm going to go back to
the starting soon for a couple minutes
and we will see you guys here in a
couple minutes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right so so chat tell me right now
does this does this look fine
uh now clearly i'm gonna have to you
know like there's there's plenty of
unused real estate but like i said
i am gonna have a
a
overlay made to make this look a lot
better eventually just today
is
it's gonna look a little a little rich
[Music]
[Music]
i'm waiting
and you see uh
king just just
just that we clarify real quick before
the show
because it might be just me and you for
a little bit before cog shows up just to
clarify
did you see
the um
the leaked fraternal shots
no
yes there's leaked return on pc shots
right now on the internet and it
probably looks amazing and navidia
commented and said i hope you guys watch
the show with us
wow
wow
the game is going to look great you know
i don't know what people would really
expect
it's supposed to look fantastic
it's a better processor it's a
it's unlimited so what the hell oh
you started
[Music]
all right here we go guys
turning us turning the thing up
and us
3
24
20 23.
it is full screen
why do people keep saying that full
screen
resident evil
oh
what the remake
oh yes
i'm about this
hell yeah
let me buy the game that i played
already again
i'll buy it again too
it's reimagined though you understand so
i'm i'm down with all this i'm about all
that smoke it look dope
we're outside
oh
it should look like this on the series x
oh yes you me
the wrong spot to vacation eh
oh it looks so good
hell yeah guess who's buying
you better pizza on gamepad
oh man come on i always get all the
resonators
my son tried to get me to buy that
package this week with the resident
evils i was like i got those games for
real no
[Music]
bread's gonna evil
can be different
yo his shirley never looked better baby
if i could just forget what happened i
don't know he's getting a little weight
down low though
yo everybody got a second man i got that
gold he got that
leon
it can be different
oh it's also in development we got
nothing to show though
sony baby you got some great playstation
updates march 24th
that's what i'm talking about next year
coming to ps5 with playstation vr2
content also in development oh they're
making that ps uh that resident evil 4
vr thing for them too state of play
returns and we've got some great
playstation updates to share with you
today
thanks to capcom for kicking it off with
resident evil 4. coming to ps5 station
our first look at playstation vr2
looks just like playstation get a sneak
peek at four games in development for
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
let's go you know what you can bet
i ain't playing this
i'm changing
oh my god i still haven't played the
game
i'm a fraud
man
oh be careful
[Music]
what are you doing
it's just like the playstation 4 i'm
gonna play
[Music]
i had to change it real quick guys he
was a little ahead of us
we outside can't have king ahead he got
like that
no i i wasn't feeling that i was i ain't
gonna lie i wasn't feeling you're
getting the news first i'm sorry man i
heard it first
oh playstation vr2 baby you
of all people have the audacity to
question me
what have you done to ensure the future
of this forsaken city uh-oh
you who have brought nothing about the
chaos i already told you i'm getting my
playstation vr
that's
the tower cries out for blood
yes
[Music]
this looks good
i'm not the biggest pr person but i
think i was playing
walking dead
is it is it me or are they just getting
all the oculus stuff finally to their
platform it's what it is man but it look
good dirt it look good so me baby
[Music]
if you don't care for vr get up out of
here son
yeah i heard vr
big sony outside
okay
[Applause]
don't look like no man's sky in the
spitted ace with the guns and i know
guys i know that the stream's messed up
right now oh i was right i was right
[Music]
the king has done it again
i'm watching oh
oh the vr2 we back again at oh oh
yes
where are you taking me
pocket books ready
i asked you a question get your man
purses unstrung
everyone says race is a good shot oh
there you go
i'm gonna ride your
okay okay
slide monster
ah
we're underwater bro
the fidelity
[Music]
six weeks of my life
i love it six weeks and it's old find
out
they're gonna give you the initial
bangers and that's it
yo this looks better than the real game
shout out to redemption mode
yes
i'm about this this is finally the power
[Music]
yes
[Music]
are open stomp them into oblivion oh hi
i'm ben mccaw narrative director at
gorilla i hope you enjoyed your first
look at horizon hall of the mountain
coming exclusively to playstation vr
we're also happy to announce that a big
update to horizon forbidden west
included
will be available to download on
playstation 4 and playstation
big sony outside right man yo you got to
play it to get to the
oh
whatever
i'm still good though i'm still good i'm
yeah i'm still get the vr
echoing for details on this free update
please check out the playstation blog
you have from all of us at gorilla
tv for your continued support it
couldn't be
someone i listen to someone listening to
it
well it was coming to probably coming
through my head since i got these posts
maybe it's coming from you a playstation
fan favorite oh coming to pc
you know the way she said it no ain't
nobody feeling that it's fraternal it's
returning oh
yo yo hold up hold up you really need to
can
he's going for the boat
[Music]
these days would never happen here we
are
get the bag
embrace the bag
remastered oh okay all right okay then
what you got
yeah yeah he said the scene wasn't
outside before haha
hopefully you got your playstation
what's this i remember this one with the
kids is the
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know why i'm interested in this
game he's got the bubonic son he
carrying it on his back
real quick to see the audio
okay
his eyes though who's your
[Music]
i think this was on xbox stage two i
believe nah it was it was a place that's
just we do not want litter box
with the litter box
they try to hit us with little box
studios with that
i can honestly say because obviously we
can't talk uh
you know we
what you did what happened
we can't talk about this is on iop
sunday
like this
yeah but it's a straight oh we out here
with straight july 19th just get it
that's what i'm talking about okay july
19th let's get it let's go let's see we
can
[Applause]
that's right you better go subscribe now
i hope your wallet is ready for this
camera's adjusted for true oh
shout out to the two dollar sticker from
the dusty oat uno
oh craft hole
oh that's a thing that's a dead space
this is just one energy
oh
that's that dead space so
spiritual successor did you know
oh just like you would hey uh chat real
quick tell me if the audio would us
sound fine like do you think we should
be a little louder or the audio should
be a little louder i i want a good
balance that's your role
man sweaty though you gotta let that go
it better look like that when you come
up oh
get up against the oh heads
locked
down it's real up in rikers i'm just
trying to said he ain't got no weapons
they got robot ceos oh
yo
you're man
[Music]
play after the stream and also makes me
chill
[Applause]
oh
kalisto stone looking right joe sandwich
striking distance let's get it yeah i
forgot this is on xbox thank you for
promoting he likes that
is it
yes it is on xbox that's on everybody
that's a multiplayer
[Music]
division that's what much got left
out of them there will only be the
victorious
what was this
gunshot oh
[ __ ] shot yes take them out
max payne on rollerblades
i'm not gonna lie they got the murder on
the murder death kill
jet set radio with the gun
yo this
joe blaze you out with this yes sir sony
baby
baby
let's get it your wyatt look like this
baron lando
it's just you and one dude in the ship
the world is
[Music]
that's crazy playstation 4 vibes
sometimes
[Music]
we'll be here we'll keep the light off
any motel six fighters
bro
don't be worried about coming up don't
stay awake
come on now
breakfast in the morning
[Applause]
i look forward
but i don't know if it was turn based
that wasn't me
little personal vibes you know what i'm
saying what is it
eternites eternites
[Music]
early 2023 because the playstation 4 is
going to be around in 2020.
you got mad time to get there
don't worry you don't get it now you can
get it later
this journey doesn't make it
is
oh there she go
you gotta define her in the dog
she got the bracelets on though you're
gonna be able to make your own character
hey y'all started from the ground up
training
oh she also her child and masterjohn
what's up
oh that's my dude
i'm so lost right now
i got the
truck outside
[Applause]
i like that
let's get it
fgc community
let's get it oh let's see if it's on the
playstation network one
with the oh god break the [ __ ] right
here completely different tone it just
says exclusive to the playstation 4
man oh he grabbed him by the throat
oh
exclusively everywhere looking at the
bottom
online multiplayer we should play us
plus
[Music]
okay
that's a multiplayer i feel like they
would have said it's a very unique
auction i don't know if everybody like
street fighter 6 gameplay
okay
[Music]
it better be on your network if it's not
that's an l let's see l
27th better it'll be cool if it's on the
network wow they gotta wait longer
yo
they say yo pop pop buy that
buy that
[Music]
is female she only she saw
what she captured
[Music]
she carries the sounds of this susan
you know that's too many waterfalls for
playstation 4 they're gonna have to cut
back on a couple of
it's still gonna show up though mm-hmm
2025.
[Music]
grandma do you ever think that the
playstation 4 will go away
you can ride with me playstation 4 oh
team up with a
when the buddy now how far do you think
we can go in 2025 jim said though
[Music]
oh mom
i want a light on them
does it have ray tracing no
we gave up on radiation
color style
seasons
a letter to the future in the future
2025
autumn 2022
[Music]
to the other stuff
he said i hope you like this
in a world ruled by tyranny and turmoil
there are those who fight to take back
control of their fate sounds like so
caliber and a sword of sword and sorcery
these people before
[Music]
no that's how fifteen
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay
let's go they got all the stomachs why
are they fighting each other yes battle
of the summons
oh this is interesting
what's going on with the summit there
will be lots of bad little materials
[Music]
who has all the damn materials
that was a good trailer that was a good
job yeah yeah you got the playstation
dudes out there wild i look fine no they
they've officially they're in spaces
already they ain't even watching them
let's go
look at it
no it's already exclusive yep so oh oh
next year next year okay that's a big
one that's a lot of people say that was
coming out this year
that's a big one it's not
you missed absolutely nathan sir
sure what's up no god of war and um what
do you figure well
it wasn't going to be there
yeah
what did this show first there was
nothing i mean i thought i missed one i
think you did miss one but i don't think
it would happen you got here for the
good stuff straight
that's stuff that you buying on the 12th
hi that's right
i'm gonna tune in i'm gonna check my i'm
turning on my playstation just to see
him like did he get that
but i thought it was botox nah nah i
thought you was gonna do the litter box
thing except for all of us like we're
all on the screen little box studios we
don't want none of the litter boxes
all right so so hold up we're on the
screen uh this thing's over so so you
know because we got to talk about the
spider-man thing now
oh yeah yeah spider-man go into p
c oh rezzy before uh remake you missed
that card
with it so capcom is i mean it's for the
streets though yeah
capcom is outside that's what's up and i
know i love their state of places they
stay to play tip their hand and let
everybody know what everybody else is
doing so they be like yo we got this but
it's for everybody so
the final fantasy if ever yeah we
confirmed street fighter is is is that's
what that's
that's what's
uh i did look no one is saying it's not
but to me
they're very extra without
and look at the last day to play
remember they announced like those uh
couple square enix games exclusive like
yeah if it was exclusive it would have
been there there's no way let's see
let's see what the streets are saying
the streets are saying help
because a lot of stuff we saw was for
the streets but but we what we did see
that final fantasy
oh man yeah that looked out that's a big
they got
that's
it's weird though it's like it's really
not publicizing you to really dig in
clever just posted street fighter 6 is
coming to the series s to the next
that's right thank you so what is it
like a time does it like no no it's
coming it's coming the same time okay so
it's so okay because they they have no
problem throwing out the word timed
exclusive either so that is true that is
true they just did the work so from an
exclusive standpoint what did they have
they had um
yeah um and the vr stuff the vr stuff
there the vr
and you know what all they did was vr
because you missed some of that
yeah they just got the [ __ ] that's
already in oculus
game oh they have to walk a day game
for the 900 i mean you got it man it'll
look good no no for the die so you know
a lot of these dudes don't have a
playstation 5. all they do is cap so
they got a playstation 4. you can't play
the defeat playstation vr 2 on the
playstation 4. so
nine hundred dollars for you you gotta
pony up and you know close excuse me you
gotta go in there gotta get that money
up and you gotta go get that you know
playstation five and oh listen stockx
got that so you can stop capping and go
get it go get it go do that oh my god
[Music]
dr she do it
i give that show eight yeah a eight out
of ten i loved it
great state of play great state of play
i loved it resident evil 4 final fantasy
whatever two next three five to six
yeah but listen by state of play
standards that was good
they've ever had that was really nice
they got in and got out without getting
wet it was dope yeah and they showed a
lot of games like yeah sure a lot of it
was like the vr stuff i wasn't
interested they did something that i
didn't think they could do
they made me interested in final fantasy
we got to read my man right quick i'm
breaking protocol fonzarelli gaming man
thanks for the commentary on the show
coach lords i will appreciate being able
to finally chill out and relax for the
first time my last brother i was
thinking about you i owe you a phone
call i'm glad you're doing better i know
the crew reached out but i i know it's
good to see you in here brother we all
thinking about you as a community love
my brother fonzarelli gaming salute
yeah yeah seven seven eight i would say
yeah i was saying i'm going more eight
because you didn't see the earlier stuff
the early stuff this is a strong two
dollar super chat from king one supreme
key uh king dave shout out to jim
hashtag wholesale hashtag yo club real
quick on that street fighter x two
dollars
from flames she's playstation showed up
today not bad
yeah
they definitely got outside they
definitely did what they were supposed
to do playstation vr too for those
people that's looking you know what's
funny
the fact that this was such a good show
oh
callisto protocol
for everybody though the f the fact that
this was such a good show
and yeah
it was on the xbox show
the fact that this is such a good show
it was such a good showing
and i have a feeling there's going to be
people because that spider-man was
announced they ain't cool like that [ __ ]
people i don't care what's crazy what's
crazy
no but what's funny is before the part
before this stream yeah where turtles
got leaked that it was coming to pc and
so did uh um
the the launch title for the ps4 might
have been ps5 one of the uh
welcome welcome you know it's about time
corporations don't care about your
feelings and welcome to the family
welcome to the club we know resident
evil 4 is coming to us oh and they're
getting residents
vr they're getting resident evil 4 vr oh
vr aspects
oh yeah they said we we have it vr
aspects what they're probably going to
do is just give you the vr version if
you buy the vr game i thought that i'm
going to be real you know i'm now beyond
i thought that we all looked good i
looked horizontally whatever that looked
good like graphical daily like triple a
quality level graphics look really good
yeah like they had a strong show it was
good it was really even considering i
don't like vr that much
it was still a good show like they got
off the vr so quick so quick they went
in they see that's what they do good
they pacing it in out boom boom for the
most part and and for them i would say
this is good because i felt like the
last couple of state of plays eh you
know what i'm saying but let's know what
they had to do before the 12th they knew
what they had to do they had to come out
they had to show some stuff they had to
get the mind share yeah right now strike
while the iron is hot shut up don't
don't don't don't trip over yourself
show some good stuff i love the fact
that tunic comes out on the 27th you
know for those people that didn't get a
chance to try it go out and try it it's
a dope game um also straight comes out
and what what was that june or july
uh um
she got the date on straight but yeah
yeah but but i'm gonna have one on my um
playstation premium plus yeah yeah yeah
that was in the business yeah that's
huge because we already know that nobody
want to buy kitty litter so
you're gonna stop with the little box
studio slam it interesting
that's dope because i will say this day
right
i will say that it's very interesting
that
they are doing
because there was a lot of rumors going
around that
um you know it's a possibility that
final fantasy 16 was going to come out
the end of this year
right so it's been it's it's coming out
in 2023 did they give a legit release
date or was it just
summer
i don't know if that's like
like the people control the summons that
you're just fighting like yeah people
are using them or is that like something
they've got fighting in the back yeah
remember it's cross-gen so you ain't
controlling no summons okay unless maybe
the playstation 5 version you control
summons in the playstation 4 you watch
summons
you realize on the ps4 version you
controlled summons and
i'm talking about moving them around and
having them fight on the big screen
that's not happening
i was saying are they going to fight on
their own in the background or is it
going to be like cut scenes only right
i'm kind of curious how that's but i
will say that is the only trailer that
may be even remotely curious in final
fantasy 16 like it wasn't a problem it
went from
i don't think i'm gonna mess with that
game to that's probably a day one now so
someone keeps saying the whole site so
slow mo what's your rating you feeling
it you what you like the most slow cause
he popping off in the chat seriously
time for slow yeah it's slow well yeah i
just want to know where you're at what's
your rating for the show y'all put in
the chat slow-mo i can give you a little
real quick
one to ten you know what i'm saying i
gotta go up and go honestly i got last
word but oh yeah that's right
shout out to naked hd we don't want to
know your rating for the show [ __ ] hd i
don't want to know about you
but we do want everybody else you don't
want it
man
very solid show eight that's the
difference says no playing feeling like
come on
how many how many people plan to get the
playstation vr
because that dictates how how how
how highly you rate the show
because if you don't see i i have no
plans like that i have no plans on
getting that vr and it's still an eight
to me because like they showed you what
they wanted to show you but they didn't
show it to you long it's like what man
what the horn said it was seven to eight
but i'd be nice by the time like what i
liked about it is by even if you add all
the the vr stuff together by the time
i'm like this dream the oh it's over
well i gave it a 7.
i might i might give it a 9. metroid
i might give it a 9 off of the strength
that
nexus is out here
i've never seen you so excited to see
your logo that's my heart
i told dudes when they purchased them
that was gonna be the most important
studio in that whole stable spiderman
look damn good and i don't think that's
the only guy you're ready i don't think
that's the only game because like i said
before before this thing oh he's saying
a whole slate for the pc cadillac that's
what slow is saved
before this this stream
there was
oh man super chat's coming in will you
get those real quick cog yeah with tour
fill that with the five pound super chat
just gonna send some love for the lord
see you hopefully on street fighter i
guess or sgf i don't know sgf summer
games fest okay an xbox event live if
you wanna stream it good night yeah yeah
we gotta go we got you playing with the
two outside xbox gotta put a damn good
show next week we shall see oh let's go
slow messy
i gave you i gave you guys that
now uh look at that real quick
i put it in the chat now i'm going to
bring it up on the on the chat
this
is what was leaked before and a lot of
people thought this was what was
actually going to get shown but it
didn't
uh so you know it does look like i don't
know if it's going to happen like right
now but sooner or later like you can
look at this like oh yeah return
like and i don't think these are fake
because if you look at these these are
too detailed to be fake look they don't
care about feeling about this bag jim is
about this bag
i love jim i know he's outside i mean i
got my money i got my boat i picked my
boat up he just sent me out i got my
boat so uh i was outside you know i
can't be in high seas but i'm getting
there you know they working on it but
i'm not gonna lie
nexus showed out today if there's a
developer
that needs to get uh uh what is it yo
what y'all like y'all like platinums
right
you need a platinum
[Laughter]
mixes has platinum sony okay
[ __ ] with you all late games is coming
all of it yo your cupboards will be big
slo said they got the whole return
store pages on steam like the whole is
loose let's go let's go and then the
crazy i think
you know in terms of like xbox side
this stream was good for them too
because it showed that
street fighter 6 is not an exclusive
because that was that would have hit
them hard that was an exclusive so you
know i don't know about that
it showed that you know some of these
multiplats that playstation's been able
to secure
there might not necessarily be
multiplied going forward uh so i'm very
interested in that the thing that i'm
curious about
is
there's no god of war
no foreshadowing
yeah i wouldn't i wasn't expecting well
i wasn't expecting god
but part of me was like maybe they'll
tease like their
big showcase third party show
yeah but they showed first party vr
titles too so yeah i mean what i'm
talking about is that like it's like the
the subliminal sneak that they usually
do like they showed you the vr for
horizon and like yo we got this update
for the re for the regular title like i
was expecting something like that where
you know at the very end maybe it would
show like the emblem for god of war and
then there's like a date for for like
the big showcase i i think um the only
reason why you saw horizon
is because of the vr guys because of the
vr presence right they had a slate of vr
games that was a nice update for horizon
that's a great
nice update where they had their
performance mode yeah
gameplay
there's more about this spider-man thing
marvel spider-man miles morales will
come to pc in fall of 2022
that's right all that all that's right
y'all got something uh this you know in
september when when they're getting you
getting spiderman
so
definitely return those coming to pc
spider-man miles and spider-man
remastered it's coming to pc
boys
most likely he's coming to pc soon
because
he said what you said uh sack boy is
coming yes
back boys and second
boys boys
is like ps5 games and both of them are
coming to people
because they're no remember the the
thing was is people said they're not
good remember like the new thing was is
people are saying oh sony's gonna
release games on pc but like four years
later
nah now we're outside early
see what what what would you realize
anyway right so all you pc dudes all you
all you playstation dude's got a high
power pc right so he tested your chin
it doesn't get you yeah you got a high
power pc go out there get the game now
we don't want to hear about it don't
fight don't fuss it don't matter if you
come out and they remember people said
that yo i said i'll leave the
playstation ecosystem if i see this
there's no need so now it's your
opportunity there's no need to have a
playstation now we see it
there's no need you messy stop it
stop
now you can get rid of your spider-man
playstation 4
it don't look good it don't look better
than the pc right now
there's always going to be a d for
castle no there's no need for the place
for the people who had moral high
[Laughter]
boy
what i like about this is
it's just showing that's like look like
they did a good job showing third party
well they showed street fighter well you
know they showed that the cgi then went
straight into the the cut scene and that
didn't that felt
longer than it was you know what i'm
saying like that that's what place
that's what xbox needs to work i'm going
to get jd gaming is that good
sorry i was just saying like that good
transition between cgi and gameplay
because right there this this set of
play showed you could do both very well
mm-hmm shout out to capcom for putting
the trailer together next year
shout out to jd gamer files which is so
we getting three five six on xbox or not
yeah it's confirmed street fighter 6
the whole thing jd game it is coming
next finally the f of the fighting game
community that's it man this is the
whole gender this is a whole new
generation first of all
little man outside winning so there was
no way see before they was winning they
could dictate you ain't winning now
little man outside shaking you up street
fighter street fighter need to be a
little man y'all know what it is
and guess who could play it little man
let's see
my pc my hot pie pc rig right here hey
anybody looking for a playstation 5. hit
me up 900.
it's like i don't need it no longer i
don't need it no more i don't need a
number
i got that i got a hop-off pc i don't
care you got to tweet that you got to
tweet that you don't need my piano
[Music]
it's not necessary no more
good show man
we're gonna go ahead and wrap this up
yeah we already have people got stuff
they gotta do i'm appreciative for
coming through we will uh be starting to
do the promo tweet stuff in the next
couple days on
the saturday show you know we've got got
the people locked down for the most part
might need a you know do a little
tweaking here and now uh people saw the
way i did the the live reactions i will
eventually have an overlay made for that
i'm gonna send out for one today
hopefully we'll be able to get it before
the podcast but not for the podcast but
the reaction next week i'll try can't
make no promises uh but it was a good
show man it was a good show i really
enjoyed that show yeah our id says bob
and ryan's coming to see yes we
confirmed delilah is horizon forbidden
west coming to see probably um like it
looks like the catalyst looks like after
a year
six months man or whatever but i don't
know what anybody definitely since nixon
has a slate of of you know once they
finish with you know spider-man god war
all that you know you're gonna get
around to that that's gonna go right
next workload is hot you know how it
there's nothing left there for you to
hold on to
pc baby
somehow
somehow some way this man is going to
bring up this exact topic on ielts of
course of course because odo does it
thanks eleven thirty eight five shot
modern warfare two was not in the show
maybe not a playstation well there's a
nice there's a lot of rumors saying that
the
playstation gave up the marketing rights
for call of duty that's right because
you know where it belongs it belongs
over here with us but see i don't know
if that's true but if if it is true i
wouldn't be surprised like
so why would someone
2 super chat pc has all the games my 30
70 ti is very happy that's right well
then um live barracks i did miss a
couple sort of chf finals of a chat
great show as always capcom looked at
that low check from sony for street
fighter 6670 got street fighter 5 sales
flashbacks and laughs all the other
rules oh that's how i beat with that
all right so we're going to hit this up
for you guys hit us with more super
chats
uh as you got to move your screen over a
little bit to the left my left not yours
i look man
the camera's too big i can't
i get it there's a little bit of room
over here i can't help that uh but i
appreciate every coming through man
we're gonna go ahead in this stream we
will see you sunday
when we do the irelords podcast xbox
prediction show why he got the throat
alert like yes so we're gonna do that
it's playstation live
we're gonna end it with